[Music]
denis villeneuve has a grasp on
character driven narrative small in
scope or large in scope
thanks to frank herbert here's a story
that's on that scale but with characters
and relationships and stories
you know these were the things that made
me want to act there is no call we do
not answer there is no faith that we
[Applause]
betray june is the story of the atridis
family that falls into the trap set by
the emperor who is getting more and more
jealous of their growing popularity
house of tradies stands as a beacon
where every other house in that galaxy
is in reference to that either as
enemies or as friends
he wants to not only make sure that his
people survive but that his son is the
kind of leader that he thinks he should
be paula tradies is the son of duke leto
and lady jessica and my initial
conversation with denis was simply
begging him to you know be able to take
part in the film
the great houses look to us for
leadership and this threatens the
emperor gurney alec and duncan idaho did
feel like big brothers you know they rip
him especially jason he's the protector
of the traders i mean he's definitely
the head knight who watches over the
family not a car
that's a sworn duty i mean that's what
any honorable
knight soldier does now that dad i mean
that's his family which we believe for
bernalillo is a combat trainer he's a
warrior oh man a fight
he's a very strict but fun visceral
paternal maternal he's all of those
things to paul
politics
lady jessica is part of the order of the
ben and jesuit
[Music]
this order that she's a part of
we can say mako perhaps the
non-traditional
partner to do gleto this group of women
who carries enormous strength and power
they are bodyguards they are fighters
they can read people
and this is what jessica is having to
deal with being a mother a lover and
this being a jesuit
how can the emperor
take
everything we've built and give it to
that joke
where is a gift not a gift
every movie needs is it's a bad guys and
the darkenings are the old ancestral
enemies of the treaties the argent have
been a very dark sadistic family in this
galaxy frankie bird created a very
powerful character into baron vladimir
arkhanel he just shows up and then his
shadow looms throughout the film he's a
cause of many people's death he feeds
off fear he feeds off of pain he's a
vicious sadistic person
a squeeze rather squeeze hard
and the ferment
kill them all
the feminine native tribes
people living in the deep desert they
have the capacity to adapt to the
toughest environment deep eat massive
sand storm dangerous predators all
around
stilgar is is the leader of the fremen
he is a powerful character his warrior
but also as a warrior
he worries about the future
take good care of your family
dr claims and the surface was seemingly
just somebody who's an ecologist someone
who cares about the foreign but then you
start to understand how much pressure
she is actually under
paul is dreaming about this strange
young woman
that keeps talking to him in his dream
she feels like an old friend again and
someone that like
wants to guide him
johnny is native to
arrakis she's used to this hostility
between her people and the people that
are trying to take from her land she's a
fighter at the end of the day
house of tradies and the harkin of an
ancient grudge and the forces that
they're up against are much greater than
he had anticipated
they're on a path of conflict and it's
the moral catalyst to paul's arc towards
something greater
[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people
is all i've known
what's to become of our world
[Music]
[Applause]
a boy
hey duncan can i trust you something yes
always you know that
i've been having dreams
about a girl or maracas
i don't know what it means
dreams make good stories
but everything important happens when
we're awake
hey you put on some muscle i didn't
no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile gurney i am smiling the emperor
asks us to bring peace to arrakis house
to tradies accepts
[Music]
i know you're still allowed
there's something awakening in my mind
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready
you've never met arkansas they're
god in heaven
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're taking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
dad
what if i'm not the future of house of
treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead
he's called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you